et c'est donc ce TGV Paris La Rochelle
qui a arraché une catenire l'incident
c'est produit vous le voyez sur une
ligne classique à Mont au sud de tour il
était 20h30 lorsque le train s'est
immobilisé en pleine voie un autre TGV a
dû être affraité pour transférer les
passagers après 4 heures d'attente les
explications Brian
Bok pour les passagers du TGV
8369 à destination de La Rochelle l'
tente se fait longue il est 20h30 quand
le train arrache une caténire sur 100 m
au niveau de Mont le TGV qui transporte
535 voyageurs est alors immobilisé le
trafic est coupé lorsque l'incident
s'est produit donc le trafic a été
bloqué sur les deux voies donc on essayé
le plus rapidement possible au moins de
récupérer une voie pour faire circuler
les trains sur une seule voie donc on a
quelques trains à destination de Lille
Paris ou bordeau sens qu'on a pu faire
passer donc au ralenti puisqueon avait
quand même permis aux clients de
descendre du train pour pour prendre un
petit peu d'aair puisqu'on avait pas de
climatisation à bord problème le train
est horors service la sn7 alors dû
affritter une rame venant de Paris pour
transborder les passagers dans un autre
train l'opération aura commencé à minuit
et duré 45 minutes avec l'aide des
pompiers que que nous avons mobilisé
avec la gendarmerie on a ben
justement transvasé ces ces 500
personnes d'une rame d'un rame à l'autre
voilà la rame qu'on a amené donc il
fallait aussi un certain délai pour la
la cheminée sur place on y a mis des
plateaux repas à bord pour que les
clients lorsqu'ils arrivent ici donc ça
s plateau repas 1000 bouteilles histoire
qu'ils puissent poursuivre leur voyage
dans les conditions les meilleures à 1
heure le train pe rep en direction de La
Rochelle avec près de 4 heur de retard
la cause de l'incident reste à
déterminer mais selon la SNCF la rupture
de la caténire proviendrait des
températures de ce weekend des chaleurs
qui auraient détendu le câble qui
aliment le train en
électricité